Is NASA lying to us?
What's happening?
Antarctica is GAINING ICE!
WHAT?!
GLOBAL WARMING?!
HOW?!
Commonly, during these climate change, global
warming conversations, people point at the
horizon and shout, the polar ice caps are
melting!
But guess what, they're not.
NASA says so.
In fact, according to new research, Antarctica
has gained so much ice, it's overbalanced
for the ice the continent has lost.
From 1992 to 2001, the continent gained more
ice than it lost to melting to a tune of 112
billion tons every year!
So wait, if global warming is real, how come
Antarctica's ice is thickening?!
Okay, so, I apologize for the slightly clickbaity
headline, but to be honest, whether they're
lying to us a real question!
But did anyone lie?!
No, Internet buddies.
No.
In fact, this ice research is consistent with
other papers climatologists have released.
In 2013, NASA's Earth Observatory announced
Antarctic sea ice had set a new record, another
study said the same thing in 2012!
There's more sea ice now than the 1981 to
2010 average levels!
I know what you're thinking, because I thought
the same thing.
If the globe is warming, how can Antarctica
be gaining ice?!
Okay so, don't believe the hype.
Research still states, unequivocally, Antarctica
is still losing ice at a fantastic rate across
most of the continent.
Ice has increased in "East Antarctica and
the interior of West Antarctica."
But other parts of Antarctica are still melting.
A lot, a lot.
So, let's be clear… gaining sea ice at this
point is actually bad.
Yep, you heard me.
Bad.
Well, there's an annual cycle of sea ice melt
and freeze, where ice is at it's lowest point
in February and March, and thickest in September
and October.
And according to a new not-yet-published paper,
from a NASA Goddard, scientist brought to
our attention by DiscoveryNews writer Patrick
J. Kiger: global warming and climate change
are actually INCREASING the sea ice.
See, melting glaciers have been depositing
freshwater into the Southern Ocean, and if
you think about seventh grade science: which
freezes first saltwater, or freshwater?
Exactly, saltwater has a much lower freezing
point; it can get colder before freezing.
This paper's conclusion is the top layer of
water surrounding Antarctica has been diluted
by the massive freshwater melt from the ice
shelves and freezes more easily today than
in previous decades!
The 2012 study found a 1.5 percent increase
in sea ice accumulation each decade.
And this isn't the only paper reaching this
conclusion.
According to a 2012 paper in Nature which
also predicted this effect, it's happening
more quickly in the real world than it did
in their model; which is even more troubling.
In a few more years, the new author James
Hansen says, "it will be clearer," because
the sea ice will continue to expand.
Even worse, however, is the overall ice trend
is still more melty than freezy.
It's melting and freezing and MELTING and
freezing.
Plus saltwater underneath the freshwater dilution
is still warming thanks to the overall climate
trend.
NASA scientists are quick to say, that it
is very difficult to accurately measure all
of these things, because of snow levels sitting
atop the ice, and the constantly changing
landscape of such a large area!
The big learning from this, is that even though
the UN announced in 2013 a .27 millimeter
per year sea level rise, and blamed it on
increasing sea ice; there's more than meets
the eye.
NOAA say YES the seas ARE rising, the thing
is, now we aren't 100 percent sure why.
Which is almost scarier if you think about
it.
Moving forward, scientists know they have
to learn even more about what is causing the
sea level rise, because it might not just
be ice melt.
The oceans have warmed about zero-point-one
Celsius over the last century, in the top
700 meters, and though that seems small, that's
just an average!
Something so small, over something as large
as the ocean, could completely change the
topography, weather, and expected behavior
of the largest single entity on Earth.
Yikes.
So, climate people, who I assume have already
left this video huffing and hoing, more sea
ice doesn't mean no global warming, but in
fact MORE global warming.
You're welcome.
Sincerely, your friend science.
How are you all feeling about this?
Tell me in the comments.
Check out
DiscoveryNews.com's piece on this as well,
and if you're concerned about what would happen
if all the ice in the world melts, Julia assuages
your concerns over here -- or maybe she doesn't,
you'll have to find out !
TestTube now has a newsletter!
Get a weekly round-up of our most popular
videos across all our shows at TestTube.com/fwd